♫ Guadalajara
♫ Guadalajara ♫
- Our mariachi, Flor de
Toloache, is different
than most mariachis.
(cheering)
We're formed in New York City.
We're all women.
Most people think of mariachi
as being from Mexico,
as being men, as being macho,
and, you know, we're pretty much
opposite of all those things.
(singing in Spanish)
- I started my musical
career playing with a local,
all-male mariachi in Brooklyn.
For me, it was really hard to communicate
with other male mariachis
because of the machismo that's very vivid
in the culture and in
the genre of mariachi.
♫ Ay, ay, ay ♫
That's kind of why I wanted to start my own group,
and that led for me to
do a all-female group,
because I didn't wanna
deal with men. (laughing)
And it's not so much that people say,
"You're not a mariachi,"
but it's the fact
that they think that
we cannot play mariachi
'cause we're women and were wearing pants
and we have curly hair
and we don't look Mexican,
or (laughing) we don't have this look
that they're expecting.
♫ I can't say you let me down ♫
- As a women mariachi,
we're technically supposed
to be wearing skirts.
And, didn't work for us.
- It's one of the most passionate music
that I've ever heard.
It's just beautiful.
It's very heartfelt and I think
that's what makes mariachi so special.
It's my dream to be able to perform
and connect with people through music.
I don't think I could ask for more.
That's what keeps us going, I think.
Thank you so much!
Gracias, Nueva York!
- Thank you so much, everybody!
We love you!
(mumbling)
(applause)